if you think back I had my um you know
my my my famous deadlift tweet that was
February
2019 that tweet could have just come and
gone right haha funny moment people talk
about it joke about it for like a week
or two and then it's gone I was like no
that's not gonna happen yeah just for
context for people watching just so they
know you broke the world record uh
woman's deadlift right yeah so CU you
identified as a woman for 20 seconds
lifted the weight and dropped it and
said okay I'm a man now yes you know
what let me let me give people the let
me let me give people the proper context
of this story good so I was running the
last popup shop that I'd ever run this
is February 2019 so I'm standing at my
store my little stall I've got my
t-shirts my CDs my hoodies and stuff um
I'm in a city called Darby in the UK
which is close to Birmingham and i' I'm
I'm literally standing standing at my
store thinking about what my next move
is right I've been selling my CDs on the
streets for years and then at this point
I've been doing the popup shops for
about four years which had been my
primary source of income but it means
that I'm standing in a shopping mall for
seven days a week talking to strangers
non-stop to earn a living and I'm just
there in my mind thinking man like
what's
the what's that next thing what's that
next thing that I can do so I can take
myself to the next level as I'm thinking
this I'm scrolling through Twitter and
and I see two different stories about
men identifying as women and like
winning races and winning athletic
events and whatever I've seen this sort
of creeping up over the last couple
years and I'm like this is Goofy this is
stupid whatever um out of curiosity my
brain just went to I wonder what the
British women's deadlift record is so I
looked it up for my weight class and it
was 210 kilos and I was like oh my PB is
275 right I can pull more than a 100
pounds more around 100 pounds more than
the women's record and so I already had
the video on my phone I had a video on
my phone of me doing a 230 kilo deadlift
um so after seeing these stories just
like I like I tweet off the hip I don't
I don't plan in advance my tweets so I
just had this video and I I put I posted
it in a tweet and I just said I keep
hearing about how men have no strength
advantage over women in 2019 so watch me
destroy the British women's deadlift
record without trying PS I identified as
a woman whilst lifting the weight don't
be a big
I had 18,000 followers at the time I
posted this February 26 2019 I remember
the DAT I hit that tweet button and I'm
I'm just standing around my store you
know waiting for people to approach 9:00
am in the morning like no one's no one's
buying anything yet the mall's not even
busy and I'm just looking at my
phone and I very quickly realized
something is happening the numbers were
just going up and up and up after about
15 minutes the video had 10 10,000 views
it was just the re the retweet thing was
like moving in real time it was just
clocking upwards the likes were just
clocking upwards I was like okay like
when I posted it I I I some people
wonder oh did you have like this huge
strategy behind it like how did you plan
it I was like guys I did not plan this
it was just it was just off the cuff
right I could not have predicted what
would happen and this video just starts
going like truly viral right not not not
doing sort of okay but truly viral like
this is just it's going bananas and I'm
just I was like I don't know what done
here but something something is
happening I'm just looking at my phone
couple hours later 100,000 views by the
time uh I go to bed in the evening
300,000 views I wake up in the morning
half a million it hits a million later
that day at this stage I'm standing at
my store I start getting I start getting
emails from BBC News Sky News Sunday
Telegraph Fox News hey we've seen your
we've seen your post online and we want
to we want to talk to you about why you
did this this and we want to talk about
your thoughts on transgender athletes in
sports or we want to get your take on
this or whatever and this thing just
goes on Rich for for weeks one million
views two million views three million
views it's just going and going and
going like I I finished running my popup
shop at the end of the week this thing
is still spreading still spreading
globally people are people are D people
are laughing people are you know and big
commentators start reacting to it Ben
Shapiro reacts to it Piers Morgan about
it on Sky News um Tucker Carlson in the
USA you have to remember like I'm just a
British rapper in England at this time
Tucker Carlson on Fox News does a
segment on it and it's just going it's
just going bananas one morning I wake up
in the morning my phone is going crazy
and people are like Yo Joe Rogan just
mentioned you Joe Rogan just shouted and
I'm like dude what like what what is
happening and I listen to Joe Rogan's
recent podcast with um it was an episode
I think with Brian Ken and they pull it
up and they're talking about it and
they're laughing on on the podcast and
Joe's like who's this guy what's this
guy's name zubie I'm following this guy
right now shout out to zubie so he
shouts me out on the biggest podcast in
the world and he's now following me on
Twitter at this point maybe I have like
40,000 followers or something like that
because it's just been it's just been
growing right it's just snowballing and
then um th this went on this went on
literally for months it went it went on
for months that's a long run for a viral
clip yeah it was a long run because what
happened is it was going viral but then
I was saying yes to every opportunity so
it wasn't just the clip that went viral
but I myself went viral so because I've
been doing all this other stuff at that
time you know I've put out multiple
albums um at that point i' started my
own podcast and then suddenly people are
seeing me popping up on Sky News on uh
BBC news on uh louder with Crowder the
Ben Shapiro show right whatever I was
doing some of these recordings remotely
because I was still in the UK at the
time so all of a sudden people are just
yo who who's this guy like he's he's
interesting he's got an interesting
background he's got an interesting story
he's talented he's a good
communicator all of this stuff so it
went beyond just the you know that funny
tweet itself that was the thing that
captured the attention but then from
that point onward people were like oh
actually this guy is uh he's got
something to say he's got an interesting
message and then more doors open um I
got invited to go out to LA to do a Dave
rubin's show the Ruben the reubin report
I told Joe I was going out to LA he
invited me to come on The Joe Rogan
Experience for the first time Ben
Shapiro invited me on to his uh Sunday
special Adam Corolla invited me onto his
show any expectation that it would blow
up like that or was just like I honestly
did not rich yeah I really did not like
I I've put out so many tweets so many
posts so many pieces of content on the
internet I've been on social media for
you know at this point 15 plus years
yeah so I didn't know that I thought
that tweet would get a couple of
lol's got a lot more than that for you
because my reach was only 18,000 people
I wasn't like oh Millions how can I post
to 18,000 people and I have the
Assumption it's going to get millions of
views I was just like okay you know this
is a silly thing it's funny it's Goofy
and I just put it out there and it just
it just struck a nerve what what's
fascinating about it is it went viral in
many different spheres so it went viral
in the Sports World it went viral in the
feminist World it went viral in the sort
of political world and the soci you get
any hate from it or is it all mostly
positive very little very little and and
what's funny is um I think because it
was a bit of a Checkmate maneuver
because I just used their logic against
yeah it
was yeah so even if people got angry
it's like well what's their argument is
their argument that I'm not really a
woman because that's isn't that against
their own a woman is anyone who
identifies as a woman thing right out of
the rule book right exactly or if you
accept me as a woman if you accept me as
a woman then I actually am the British
women's deadlift Champion mhm so it was
a bit of a Checkmate maneuver where like
they people couldn't really people
couldn't really say anything and it it
wasn't just that um it wasn't just that
most people found it funny but I I'll
tell you something kind of interesting
from behind the scenes so when I went on
some of these um some of these
British um mainstream media channels Sky
News BBC obviously BBC is like the
biggest you know publicly funded you
know biggest big publicly funded media
corpor massive one in the
UK when I went on some of those
shows off camera like in the green rooms
are just in the studio rich I can't tell
you how many people were just like thank
you thank you for saying it thank you
for saying the
thing especially women right I had women
telling me like you know I've got a
daughter I've got daughters who's in
school and I'm worried about this and
that but you know I'm I'm afraid it it's
a bit like how it was during the co era
like amount of people to this day I
still get people just coming up to me
like man thank you for thank you for the
stuff you were saying during that time
because you kept me saying right because
people are thinking it but they don't
want to say it or maybe they don't have
the right words or they don't know how
to articulate it I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out